hey guys it's Justine I'm here with row
hello hi guys I'm so excited because I
got you some Christmas present you are
so sweet so these are all things that I
think that you will enjoy but the whole
appeal of this is we're gonna do this
blindfolded so you're gonna open them up
line fold it and then you have to guess
what's inside a question if I guess some
correctly do I get to keep it if I guess
I'm wrong do I not gonna keep you you
get to keep it regardless take back your
gift we got this new blindfold I would
present are you kidding me - unicorn I
know I should have worn the unicorn
holiday sweater oh my gosh there's a
unicorn holiday sweater that Justine got
me and it's the cutest I would have
matched we did the Amazon sweater home
since basically got a fashion so you
guys can go check that out as well in
the back I can't wait so I know which
one there's one that we have to open
first okay do I put this on yeah you put
that on I'm gonna movies aside okay okay
so here we go this is the first one
there you are okay it's very long feel
soft okay let's do that
let's see here I guess what's feeling me
yes it's been fixed feel don't squeeze
too hard what is this I was like using
the sweater around tight
okay my dog cookie over here she only
gets as excited when there's food is
this food know what it was - ha I'm a
precursor to a future gift I want to
make sure we got this one out of the way
this is amazing this game
you said a puppy or a fortune 500
company
well let's see what this one okay I love
that I didn't by the way oh this is it's
not a shirt but it has secrets
it does sparkles and it oh this is a
pillow do I have to guess the design
because I don't know probably a surprise
like a reindeer try again a snowman try
again
Santa try again and L know candy cane
not holiday spring not holiday it's not
it's absolutely not it's a dog no it's a
computer no it's a chai tea latte coffee
it's a coffee coffee it's a pillow yes
yeah but what's the design do you want
one more yes yeah okay I'll try the good
things I'd love that you know that I
love my also loves this oh yes but I
think I don't know it might flip oh yeah
it's one of the flip ones oh it's a flip
one huh if you go this way just total
bling so when I guess two out of two you
have so Justine give me a hard one
I'm totally ready okay I'm deaf now so
you want a hard one I'm ready for a hard
one okay well this one I didn't wrap
because I ran out of wrapping paper so
it's a bag to your satisfaction
okay
okay gif number three this feels like
the 12 gifts a Christmas it does but we
only a five or six I forgot it's one
part here you go there you go you're
ready can you eat out of it good
theoretically you can get out of
anything oh this is some type of
technical techy stuff this is a compute
mill this is because you know how they
have the instructions in here at the
little route this tech stuff has this
yeah it's definitely something fact I'll
give you that there's a cord there's a
fourth there it's definitely a
technological device now I just got to
figure out which one what Nona nope
that's instructions
that's package is not part of it I know
that's foam right there you go that's
the device oh wow what is this
what is is it's round round what the
heck is round like is it a magnifying
mirror that you put on your car or your
bike no so you can see better that's
something that you want it is a new
camera but you stick like a GoPro
minutes around and it's just the lens
absolutely bizarre the lens nope nope
this is a standing near it's that not
like the beauty gurus it's not a mirror
but it isn't wedding even plugs in as
lights there's no lights so what would
plug in does a stand that how
like I don't get this I mean what is why
is it round
did you ready to do a hint yeah well
it's a speaker so I think maybe if you
even take your blindfold off you
probably wouldn't even witness so I'm
not even children well it has to be
there's a stand yes it's it's a speaker
it Alexa googleplay no both giggle hey
Siri we have activated every single
person's possible device is it one of
those it is not but if you want to take
your blindfold off you can look okay and
then try to guess so okay this looks
different in my head I was picturing
something else she hates her good eye
oh no what it okay it plugs in back here
do you want me to tell you yeah you're
gonna have to tell me girl because this
hardmode one I did not guess it I have
no clue it is a wireless iPhone scan
charger you can put it by your bed and
what yeah so you want me to plug it in
you just put your phone right there just
touching it yes with the case on or off
you can have a case on it the christmas
came early okay let me put this over
here by my Wonder Bread all right that
was when he could he helped give it away
she did think it was food notice she did
not get that excited know it wait for
the charger she's like they're stupid
okay here we go
next one okay I can already tell you
it's soft okay yes it's not Brett I'll
give you
okay let's see it's a face oh my gosh
it's a stuffed animal it isn't it's a
puppet it is oh my gosh I just I just
stuck my hand in here and it's a puppet
oh I'm moving is Fay you are now just
which animal okay that's what we've got
to figure out let me talk about that
everything okay there's this feel
there's there's four legs there are so
it's an animal of four legs yes it's a
dog it's a dog it's a pig what type of
dog it's a dog what type of dog it's a
dog let me feel that's too frankly safe
is this a French Bulldog yes it is oh my
gosh oh my I loved when you were like I
want a copy of look I sort of have a
puppy you did get me a puppy
Oh kitty I gotta get her side by side
good eat it oh my gosh just in the color
do they actually does matter
Oh cookie loves this dog we've got one
more actually two more gifts oh my gosh
okay
oh okay we've got a box yeah I know it's
a box okay now we gotta open this an
easy-bake oven it's not easy but I want
you to hurt yourself
let me just sump it out for you oh this
is a text thing like a speaker not a
speaker I feel the tops you look what
does that feel
think about when you opened first this
this is a toaster it's a toaster oh my
gosh I thought was another tech gadget I
mean you know it's a fad technique it's
a special toaster though I don't think
you'll be able to get okay I can guess
it okay unicorns no swine no Joe Joe see
wha no is it Christmas really they're
not Christmas elated okay it's something
that we both like a movie series of
movies it's a series of movies later the
Rings well you know I haven't seen that
see oh you haven't seen here and how not
to your right a lot of Harry Potter what
else is a series here we're done things
in the dream yes these are Star Wars
toys dude shut up oh it burns in Darth
Vader on the toast are you Kenny I mean
we have to do it we have to do it says
that's attention cord let's test it out
this may have not been a test video but
we have to do it before this video ends
I am so excited I did get you some bread
wow this is amazing oh my gosh I'm so
excited about me too I'm gonna turn it
up all the way because we want to get
the fool is the best gift ever
like how freaking cool is this they had
so many different ones that I was like
oh my gosh which one do I get but I
thought breath Vader
I love Darth Vader good option so ba
yeah if you hear gurgling it's not our
tummies it's literally cookie going to
town on this dog turn it don't eat over
here she's just like losing her life now
we don't switch it we can do one more
yeah okay let's set this aside the last
gift
here you go while we toast
what is this it's tall well I don't know
what is it it is a zipper a pouch a bag
a backpack it's a backpack just seen I
really wanted a back that what kind of
back oh I guess what kind is this a mini
backpack is a mini backpack
this is have Minnie Mouse on it oh no no
no that had many and many ism like the
small backpack okay I'll give you a hint
it's a perfect size for me something
that I have not seen oh is it
Harry Potter yes but I still need to
watch yeah but I don't know what it is I
don't get it
oh I need to see this I don't know this
is cute oh my god I'm wearing this
everywhere yeah the Gryffindor little
mini backpack okay so Justine Gryffindor
is one of the houses okay at school so
there's like Griffin Gryffindor
Slytherin house Hufflepuff Ravenclaw and
I definitely would be Gryffindor that's
the rain hurry just there brave then
this is great cuz I was like I just was
like Harry Potter
[Music]
yeah you have a Star Wars one oh I
didn't I'm gonna have my hair hairy one
the problem is when I'm shopping for
other people then I get super hyped up
cuz I get the recommended thing so I got
the Nightmare Before Christmas back this
is really cute
I know yeah I was like I want to be
festive for the holidays this is perfect
we need to wear these together I know I
love it
wait until you see the DOS oh oh oh snap
stop everything did it work
oh it puts the logo into here's your
toast free let me check this one out
Wow oh my gosh doesn't get a little
extra crispy but yeah what sounds a
little hotter than the other one Oh
Merry Christmas enjoy your bread thank
you oh my gosh I love ya I get it they
go together it does I was like it's a
theme it's a theme oh my goodness well
yeah this is definitely something Oh cuz
like we didn't watch it yeah watch it
but like there's some burning stuff
happening to it I'm okay with it
okay you're really into poison alright
well thank you guys so much for watching
we hope you enjoyed this video I will
see you guys in the next one make sure
you go check out Rose channel subscribe
go say hello and Happy Holidays from us
to you yes happy holiday
[Music]